You may or may not have heard of Godel's Incomplete Theorem,
but since they are also mentioned in conjunction with the Halting Problem
and undecidability,
it worth saying a few words about them.
Godel's Incompleteness Theorem is named Austrian-born mathematician, Kurt Godel,
are concerned with mathematics,
but are actually closely related to undecidability
and as you might know, any mathematical system starts out
with a set of axioms.
What are axioms?
Axioms are statements which you assume to be true
without having any formal proof of them,
such as if A equals B
and B equals C, then A must also equal C
or you can always draw a line from one point to another point,
no matter where they are.
Those would be axioms.
Now axioms often sound very trivial, like this one here
or the fact that you can always draw a line between 2 points
but for many of them
there are actually scenarios where they are not true.
So axioms are the basis of
any mathematical theorem or proof.
Now what Kurt Godel showed, and it was a shocker at his time
and to many it is still today,
is the following:
So what Kurt Godel showed was that if you had a set of axioms
and they don't contradict each other
and they are listable,
which means you could have an algorithm that lists you all of these axioms,
so either they are finite or
they can even be infinite as long as you have an algorithm
that can produce them all; if this is the case,
then there are some statements
that are true but which you cannot prove
based on these axioms and this is what he meant by incompleteness
how he basically showed that
no matter what foundation you base
a mathematical system on,
as long as that is a consistent foundation,
then you can not prove everything
without adding additional axioms at least.
He also showed, and this is the second Incompleteness Theorem,
which is basically an extension of the first one
that a system of axioms
cannot not demonstrate its own consistency
and what that means is that
very informally,
a mathematical system can not be used to show that
it itself is consistent.
These 2 statements
are in a way very similar to the Halting Problem and Undecidability.
The axioms; you can think of those as programming statements.
So any program or algorithm
is composed of a number of simple instructions
that are then arranged,
and of course there is an infinite number of possible computer programs
that you can write, but they are made up of a fine set of building blocks
and the second Incompleteness Theorem
is of course very similar to undecidability
in the sense that it shows that
you cannot use a system to prove everything about that system,
very loosely speaking,
and the undecidability of the Halting Problem
and all of the other undecidable problems, of course
says that we cannot use algorithms
to calculate everything about algorithms.
I know that from a practical perspective
there's lots of criticism of this,
but truth be told, I just find that super fascinating.